you also have a band and i obviously
have to talk about this because i'm a
musician as well so
it's the bacon brothers so how did this
begin and what a great name
we uh you know i always played um my
brother and my sister who are
uh uh i'm the youngest of six uh so two
of them
were uh musicians they had a band when
and that's how i was a little tiny boy
my brother's nine years older than me
mine too yeah okay
and um and i used to sit and watch them
playing in the basement uh they had a
jug band which was like um it's
you know a washboard uh base and and a
washed up base and a and a plane of
washboard banjos and that kind of stuff
yeah and um and i used to just
see that and think boy that looks like a
lot of fun and then in the 90s
i had written a bunch of songs i was i
really started out just wanting to be
a songwriter that's that's what i was
doing my brother and i would write
together and a friend of mine was from
philadelphia
uh where we grew up said why don't you
come down to philly and
and put on a show and you can call
yourselves the bacon brothers which was
embarrassing because we didn't even name
the band
uh you know yeah i mean it was kind of
an obvious choice but
um anyway uh that was in the 90s and
it's like
i don't know 10 records since then and
so that's so cool